BY THE WAY, QUID PRO QUO JOE HAD
A DISASTER IS WEAK.
REALLY BAD AND WE GOT ALL THAT
ON TAPE.
WE’VE SEEN THE VERY BEST IN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IN THE VERY
WORST.
THE BEST, THE BEST DOCTORS, THE
BEST NURSES, THE BEST MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS WORKING
ROUND-THE-CLOCK, PUTTING
THEMSELVES IN HARM’S WAY.
THE BEST SCIENTISTS, MEDICAL
RESEARCHERS MAKING HISTORIC
STRIDES IN FINDING TREATMENT
OPTIONS FASTER THAN EVER BEFORE
IN HISTORY.
WE ARE NOW ALL BLESSED TO LIVE
IN A COUNTRY TO HAVE SO MANY
GIFTED AND TALENTED PEOPLE
WORKING THIS HARD.
MEMBERS OF THE U.S. MILITARY,
THEY ARE NOW ASSISTING STATES
NATIONWIDE.
THE BEST OF THE BEST, AND
BREAKING TODAY, THE PRESIDENT
JUST ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
BRINGING RESERVE FORCES BACK
ONLINE AS ACTIVE-DUTY PERSONNEL.
THE PRESIDENT ALSO INVOKED THE
DEFENSE PRODUCTION ACT MANDATING
THAT GENERAL MOTORS PRODUCED
THOUSANDS OF NEW VENTILATORS.
WHY QUESTION RICK THERE WERE
ACTING TOO SLOW
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
GM NOW JOINS ALL THESE GREAT
COMPANIES.
YOU CAN SEE THAT ON YOUR SCREEN.
THEY WILL MOVE HEAVEN AND EARTH
TO PRODUCE THE MASKS, THE
VENTILATORS, THE MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT, EMERGENCY SUPPLIES
AND GET THEM DELIVERED.
ALL THESE LIFE-SAVING PRODUCTS
FROM ALL OF THE COUNTRY, WHERE
AND WHEN NEEDED.
JUST TODAY, AIRPLANE GIANT
BOEING ANNOUNCED THAT IT WOULD
ALSO BE PRODUCING MUCH NEEDED
FACE SHIELDS.
THESE CORPORATIONS DO DESERVE A
LOT OF CREDIT.
SO DOES THE PRESIDENT, SO DOES
HIS TASK FORCE.
THEY’VE BEEN LEADING SINCE DAY
ONE WHEN THEY WERE CALLED
XENOPHOBIC AND HYSTERICAL AND
FEARMONGERS.
PUBLIC-PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS TO
DRIVING UP TESTING SITES, SEEM
TO BE HOME TESTING SITES, THE
TRAVEL BAN, THE PARADIGM SHIFT,
HOW WE WILL DEAL WITH FUTURE
PANDEMICS IS NOW LITERALLY BEING
REWRITTEN AND UNFOLDING RIGHT
BEFORE YOUR EYES.
THIS IS NOW HISTORY IN THE
MAKING.
SADLY, THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE --
I’M GLAD IT’S A MINORITY -- WHO
ARE SO AFFLICTED WITH THE RAGE,
HATRED, AND TRUMP DERANGEMENT
SYNDROME, THEY WON’T GIVE HIM
CREDIT FOR ONE THING.
LAST NIGHT, I TOUCHED ON THE
INSISTENT, NEVER ENDING,
CONSTANT COMPLAINING, AND
FRANKLY, LACK OF ACCOUNTABILITY
OF THAT GUY, NEW YORK
GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO.
HIS ESTATE IS THE EPICENTER OF
THE CORONAVIRUS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY ARE FACING A REAL CRISIS.
NEW YORKERS NEED AND DESERVE
HELP AND THE PRESIDENT HAS
RIGHTLY DIRECTED THE FULL
COMPLETE SUPPORT OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, UNPRECEDENTED
ASSISTANCE HAS BEEN GIVEN AND
WILL BE GIVEN AS
PROMISED.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDING.
CHUCK SCHUMER SAID AT LEAST OUT
OF THIS BILL, $40 BILLION THAT
WAS SIGNED INTO LAW WILL GO TO
NEW YORK.
ON TOP OF THAT, A U.S. NAVY
HOSPITAL SHIP, IT WILL BE
LEAVING TOMORROW, IT WILL BE IN
NEW YORK HARBOR ON MONDAY.
FOUR TEMPORARY HOSPITALS HAVE
BEEN, ARE BEING ERECTED BY THE
ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS.
DONALD TRUMP IS MAKING THAT
HAPPEN.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
ANOTHER 1,000 BED HOSPITAL SET
UP BY FEMA.
LOOK AT THAT.
THAT IS AT THE JAVITS CENTER IN
MANHATTAN, IN NEW YORK, TO
PREPARE FOR POTENTIAL
OVERCROWDING.
THAT’S FIVE SEPARATE HOSPITALS
THE PRESIDENT HAS SECURED FOR
ANDREW CUOMO, THE STATE OF
NEW YORK, THE CITY OF NEW YORK.
THE PRESIDENT ALSO SENT THE
NATIONAL GUARD TO HELP THE STATE
WITH LOGISTICS.
HE SAID, YEP, MORE THAN 4,000
VENTILATORS ALONE THIS WEEK.
EVERYTHING THAT NEW YORK WILL
NEED, ANDREW CUOMO HAS
REQUESTED, THE PRESIDENT HAS
DELIVERED.
BUT YOU KNOW, I WATCHED DAY
AFTER DAY, AND HE SAYS IT, HE
TALKS WITH SUCH GREAT AUTHORITY.
THESE POLITICIANS ALL TALK, NO
ACTION, THAT IS WHAT WE ARE
GETTING FROM CUOMO.
IT SOUNDS GREAT, SOUNDS
AUTHORITATIVE, SOUNDS WONDERFUL.
GAME ON MY RADIO SHOW FOR
40 MINUTES, YEAH, WE WILL ALL
WORK FOR GATHER.
TODAY, HE HAD NOTHING BUT MORE
WYOMING AND COMPLAINING.
IT’S GETTING PATHETIC, ANDREW.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING AND WHY
DIDN’T YOU PREPARE BETTER?
WE WILL EXAMINE, TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHERE THERE VENTILATORS FOUND
IN A STORAGE FACILITY OR
SOMETHING THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
CLAIMING THAT THERE WERE
VENTILATORS FOUND?
IS THERE ANY TRUTH TO THAT?
>> THAT IS INCORRECT, AND
GROSSLY UNINFORMED.
THE POINT IS, WE HAVE
VENTILATORS IN A STOCKPILE AND
WE DIDN’T SEND THEM TO THE
HOSPITALS YET.
OF COURSE WE DIDN’T.
THAT IS THE WHOLE POINT.
THE HOSPITALS DON’T NEED THEM
YET.
>> Sean: OH, THEY DON’T NEED
THEM YET.
THAT’S A NICE HOSPITAL BEHIND
YOU.
THANK DONALD TRUMP.
MAYBE ONCE IN A WHILE SAY
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE PAYING THAT BILL.
HE EVEN ADMITS THEY DON’T
CURRENTLY HAVE A VENTILATOR
SHORTAGE IN NEW YORK.
WE NEED 40,000!
OKAY, IF YOU NEED 40,000, WE
WILL GET YOU 40,000 IN PURITY
NOT EVEN USING THE 4,000 YOU GOT
THIS WEEK.
THE CIRCUMSTANCES HAVE CHANGED.
THE PRESIDENT HAS PLEDGED
EVERYBODY, HE WILL CONTINUE TO
MOVE HEAVEN AND EARTH TO GET
NEW YORK AND ANY OTHER STATE ANY
VENTILATORS, AND A MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT THEY NEED.
IT’S NOT EXACTLY BEEN THE
SIMPLEST ENDEAVOR AND APPEARED
NICE HOSPITAL BEHIND YOU.
THE COUNTRY PAID FOR THAT,
GOVERNOR.
IN THE COUNTRY.
AND THE COUNTRY DOES NOW HAVE
THE RIGHT TO GET ANSWERS FROM
YOU.
BUT THE GOVERNOR NEW YORK AND
THE MAYOR OF NEW YORK CITY.
NEW YORK IS AN INTERNATIONAL
STATE, IT’S AN INTERNATIONAL
CITY.
PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER THE GLOBE
COME RIGHT HERE.
YOU KNOW, LAST YEAR, THE STATE
OF NEW YORK, THEY SPENT OVER
$170 BILLION.
I KNOW, I LIVE HERE.
I PAY A FORTUNE IN TAXES, AS
DOES EVERYBODY ELSE.
THE CITY OF NEW YORK, THEY SPENT
ANOTHER $90 BILLION.
SO WHY DIDN’T THEY HAVE THE
EMERGENCY SUPPLIES AT ALL?
THEY SEEM TO HAVE LITTLE OR
NONE, ZERO PREPARATION.
WHAT PART OF BEING THE NUMBER
ONE TERROR TARGET IN THE COUNTRY
DO THEY NOT SEEM TO UNDERSTAND?
BECAUSE YOU’VE GOT MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE, HIGHLY CONCENTRATED IN A
VERY SMALL AREA.
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE YOU WERE NOT
PREPARED FOR EMERGENCIES LIKE
PANDEMICS?
CLOSE PROXIMITY, MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE.
YEAH, YOU WOULD BE MOST LIKELY
TO HAVE THE MOST DIFFICULTY.
GOVERNOR CUOMO, YOU ARE NOW IN
YOUR THIRD FOUR-YEAR TERM AS
GOVERNOR.
THERE’S NO EXCUSES.
SITTING THERE, LECTURING.
I NEED 40,000 OF THOSE, 60,000
OF THAT.
REALLY?
WHY DIDN’T YOU DO YOUR JOB AND
ALLOCATE THE EMERGENCY DOLLARS
FOR MOMENTS PRODUCTIVELY LIKE
THIS.
NEW YORK IS THE NUMBER ONE
TARGET IN THE ENTIRE
UNITED STATES FOR TERRORISM.
NOW ANDREW CUOMO, WE’VE LOOKED
AT HOW YOU HAVE SPENT MONEY IN
NEW YORK.
LOOK AT THIS, A WHOPPING
$750 MILLION FOR SOLAR PANEL
FACTORY.
BY THE WAY, WHERE IS IT NOW?
CLOSED DOWN.
$90 MILLION FOR A LIGHT BULB
FACTORY, A COMPANY IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHAT’S THAT?
WHATEVER HAPPENED TO THAT,
ANDREW?
OR THE $600 MILLION YOU SPENT ON
A COMPUTER CHIP FACTORY THAT
SITS EMPTY.
MILLIONS SPENT FOR BRAND-NEW I
LOVE NEW YORK SIGNS.
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU, HOW
MANY VENTILATORS, HOW MANY
GALLONS, HOW MANY MASKS, HOW
MANY GLOVES, HOW MANY
RESPIRATORS, HOW MANY
GENERATORS, HOW MUCH FUEL COULD
YOU HAVE STORED AND HAVE
PURCHASED WITH JUST SOME OF THAT
AND YET EVERY DAY, I NEED THIS,
I NEED THIS, HE NEEDS THIS, NOT
FAST ENOUGH, 40,000 VENTILATORS.
YOU ARE NOT USING THE 4,000 YOU
HAVE AND HE SITS THERE LECTURING
THE PRESIDENT AND THE
TASK FORCE.
THEY’RE MOVING HEAVEN AND EARTH,
RIGHTLY SO, FOR THE CITY AND FOR
THE STATE.
HOW ABOUT SAYING THANK YOU TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE QUESTION
RIGHT THERE MAKE THAT HAPPEN FOR
YOU.
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS TASK FORCE
ARE MAKING THAT ALL HAVE BEEN
PREPARED GREAT FOLLOW-UP IN THE
HOSPITAL THEY BUILT FOR YOU AND
DON’T FORGET, ACCORDING TO A
FORMER NEW YORK STATE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR, IN 2015.
REMEMBER?
WOW, EVEN THE LIBERAL MEDIA MOB
REPORTED THIS, "CUOMO WAS BORN
HIS STATE WOULD NEED ADDITIONAL
VENTILATORS TO MANAGE ANY FUTURE
PANDEMICS."
HE CHOSE NOT TO BUY THEM.
GUESS HE NEEDED THE MONEY FOR
THE SOLAR STUFF.
SO YOU’VE GOT CUOMO, COMRADE
de BLASIO WHINING, COMPLAINING.
EVERY DAY THEY TAKE NO
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEIR FAILURE
TO PREPARE AND WASTING, ALL THE
WASTE, FRAUD AND ABUSE ON THEIR
WATCH.
GOVERNOR, MAYOR, MAYBE IT’S TIME
YOU BE GRATEFUL TO THE FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE THAT YOU WILL RIGHTLY
CONTINUE TO RECEIVE AS A POURS
INTO THE STATE OF NEW YORK.
IF YOU HAVE ANY PROBLEMS, ONLY
3.5 BILLION.
NO, YOUR SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER
SAYS OVER $40 BILLION.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
DELIVERING ON HIS PROMISES TO
YOU AND CUOMO AND de BLASIO,
WELL, YOU NEED TO NOW START
DOING THE SAME.
WHICH BRINGS US TO EVEN A LOWER
POINT.
HILLARY CLINTON.
HILLARY ONCE AGAIN PROVING SHE
IS A NATIONAL DISGRACE.
BITTER, TWICE FAILED
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE.
NOW SEEMINGLY CHEERY FOR THE
VIRUS ON TWITTER.
TWEETING OUT "HEADLINE: U.S. NOW
LEADS THE WORLD AND CORONAVIRUS
CASES."
I AS SHE BELIEVES THAT CHINESE
PROPAGANDA PAID ALONG WITH A
MESSAGE, "HE DID PROMISE AMERICA
FIRST."
THAT IT’S A NEW LOW EVEN FOR
HER.
HEY, HILLARY, PEOPLE ARE SICK
AND PEOPLE ARE DYING.
THANK GOD THAT VINDICTIVE, ANGRY
ATTENTION SEEKER IS NOT
PRESIDENT BECAUSE SHE LOST.
YOU THINK SHE WOULD’VE ENACTED
THE TRAVEL BAN.
DO YOU THINK THAT WOULD’VE
HAPPENED WITH HILLARY?
QUARANTINE?
YOU THINK THAT WOULD’VE HAPPENED
WITH HILLARY?
THAT ONE DECISION, SAVING TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS FROM
CONTRACTING THIS DISEASE?
I DOUBT IT.
SHE WOULD’VE CALLED IT
XENOPHOBIC, RACIST, YOU KNOW,
HYSTERIA.
HILLARY CLINTON IN A CRISIS,
WELL, WE HAVE SOME EXAMPLES OF
THAT.
WE ALL REMEMBER HOW WELL SHE
HANDLED BENGHAZI AND LET’S NOT
FORGET, SHE SERVED IN THE A
OBAMA-BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, 2009
THE STOCKPILE OF MASKS WAS
TOTALLY DEPLETED BY OBAMA.